eu venho aqui não querem partilhar
convosco com disseram os almoços a tocar
infarto falar minha já nomeou os algumas
componentes nas orelhas mas sim aquilo
que devo falar um bocadinho fora da box
porque eu fui convidado ontem para
substituir o grande salvador o atacante
nesta minha esperança de termos tido em
consumistas não sei se existe a palavra
em 2003 quando devíamos louvar o
trabalho do doutor palhaço não para as
crianças com 92% dos projetos mundiais
mas para os mais velhos isto fez com que
minha bandeira mudasse
eu tenho uma maneira pesada que elas
sporting vista e para sair para uma
bandeira nova que me inspira que mudaram
muito em relação aos mais velhos
é fácil dizer se o governo as entidades
a mudar o mundo é muito mais fácil
tentamos fazer o nosso e super simples
então eu nunca digo partilhar estas mais
mil lojas que nós temos por ano em
quatro hospitais entre eles o ip8
coimbra
mais de 10 mil pessoas com quem
interagimos diretamente e mais 100 mil
nós interagimos indiretamente está sem
valores muito por alto por isso também
diz pouca coisa e vamos convidar a
viajar no tempo passava e o que os mais
velhos partilham connosco eo cria
convosco os mais novos e com muitas
vezes falamos tomar os mais novos e com
temos um erro crasso vocês o futuro
fazemos foi o que os índios não só que
acho que vou mudar o planeta pois temos
que tratar com o devido respeito e dar
aos mais jovens todas as ferramentas que
a chance tão e tem que ser você está a
mãe que mudar o mundo então quero
partilhar convosco é que vocês vão ver o
mundo no futuro para que vocês possam
mudar agora e vou pra cá só uma coisa
que eu acho que terminaria neste
processo as suas condolências
não somos das poucas instituições
mundiais trabalham com cenas com o mesmo
a diferença é muito mal visto por todos
nós
os pais fazer um bom elenco os filhos
nos primeiros cinco melhores que nós e
os meus pais não tinham pensamento minha
mãe não tinha receio nenhum em falar mal
dos filhos enfrenta toda a agenda esta
dura
pode nos fazer mal para os correios nós
vamos fazer com o coloca em que os
meninos que já apanhou nós temos a nossa
instituição foi cristiano ronaldo ter
pecado agora você imagina que é ter um
estádio como 'as hoje chamaríamos
homossexual logo aí investir cá triste e
dói transformar energia para sermos mais
forte pois aquela melhor atrás somente
de energia negativa toda a gente o
critica em algo positivo e quem é pobre
o meu foi deposto há alguma forma de
demência monstruosa e foi isso que o fez
e trabalhar com os mais velhos voltava a
dizer não jogamos nem mesmo esta frase
eu gostaria que vocês porque assim mas
95% do corpo de exemplo ao não liguem é
um lixo
gostaria que fosse o fizesse a frase
gostaria ter tido a coragem de viver uma
vida mais fiel a mim mesmo não se ganha
a vida com os vossos pais gastam
questionados disse que dizem caem no
curso não sei se processa a palavra mas
eu sou do norte se com vós o vosso
coração e há posições muito mais bonitas
com aquelas que nós vemos o quanto a
primeira vez a minha que eu ia assumir
aquilo que ia fazer à minha mãe o seu
estojo homossexual
sim mas não isso fosse mais tarde mas
ainda não quando eles ela conhecer
palhaço minha mãe morrendo porque ela
acha que ser professor e o contágio que
se a minha apresentação
eu felizmente não sou professor há dois
anos finalmente sofrido a ser médicos e
professor seja o jurista passei por
tantas são as suas costas nisto mas há
outras profissões e todas elas são tão
nobres e bonitas com o centro médico com
dois amigos no hospital existe a figura
do médico que é um deus quer queiramos
quer não tudo o próprio curso em toda a
cidade transformou homérico deus naquele
espaço
quando aparece um palhaço a dizer olhos
nos olhos que tem tanto orgulho é que eu
faço com meu público dicas força tanto
moel estabelece o código estatuto e
pagasse um carimbo fogo
eu gostei porque ela faz com vocês
gostaria de não ter trabalhado tanto
cada vez mais a empresas estão a mudar
esta mensagem
aquela sua vez não faz 8
mas o sábado eo domingo no olímpico
há coisas muito melhor fazer amor você
sabe o que é fazer humor submetem
concorrente animais estilo mantém com
álcool espetacular porque temos outros
casos com o trabalho
eu trabalho 300 horas pressionada para
mais um amigo
as 300 horas no barão haver um filho
está comigo também fechou por isso só
vou trabalhando
já sobre as empresas mudar esta mensagem
mas não é levar qualquer outro pra vocês
dentro da empresa temos jogos têm um
espaço particular
para terminar não sim mas não é uma vida
depois da empresa
estou trabalhando só vou surpreender
tendo a coragem de expressar o
sentimento eu gostei de uma rapariga dos
6 aos 12
aliás todas minhas namoradas foram
virtuais eu sei namorar com ela há cinco
anos e flores depois às vezes eles olham
agora com 16 anos ela acha que é claro
não só os pés e os sentimentos não tenho
medo de expressar o que sentem e no atp
- eu gosto uma pessoa do mesmo sexo
okay mal e ter medo e não existir amor
entre as pessoas
há pouco tempo que há instituições que
castrar quimicamente a parte sexual dos
dois mais velhos temos medo que começa
cedo e tentando ficar grávida ela faça o
109 enquanto faz opinião fazendo a cama
igual
por isso deve ficar por fora digo tudo e
israel em alguns pontos fáceis de serem
as mulheres e 17 homens ponto de sucesso
por isso pegue um bombardeio agostinho
costa costinha vai ver o empate que sim
nem que seja nem que seja para o natural
a saison fiéis aos nossos amigos mas
cada um tem um público que eu sofri como
o mais novo ter uma família que estava
sendo e continua constantemente evitar
os filhos trabalho eo atendimento nas
redes nas redes sociais nos grandes
amigos e minha família não é campeão
daquela senhora que abandonou em abril
as pernas e sem qualquer coisa àquelas
pessoas que estão conosco e não é ter
cinco mil amigos no facebook que tem
muitos amigos
eu tenho privilégio ter bons amigos e ea
minha família são o suporte quando as
coisas muitas vezes não estou muito bem
por isso cria redes de amigos e faça uma
proposta quando seria agora no intervalo
vão ter com a mãe que não conhecem e
diga uma coisa como essa pessoa
todos nós temos coisas lindíssimas tenho
e sejam felizes
isso é a coisa mais importante é sermos
foi isso não tenho dúvidas
o dinheiro ajuda lá custava ter um teste
uma vez o papa formas faz a mesma coisa
há uma sociedade muito diferente é fácil
sermos foi isso nós complicamos a malta
cada vez à tona a querer milhões no
banco só como locação e ser ficha hora
porque eu tô vida toda a trabalhar
esqueça os amigos que essa mulher me
esqueço o filho porque acho que quer ter
o ferrari um porsche e região já com
descaso uma pequena oficina mas a caixa
tanto prazer em ler por aqui uma senhora
estava parado numa rotunda o carro
avariado passaram-me as suas por aquela
senhora ninguém para o pátio da não quer
dizer que seja melhor do que aquela
pessoa mas estão em uma aplicação nos
corpos só usamos como chamar a atenção
para as coisas que nós devemos ser
interventivo
temos aqui um exemplo de manhã que é
extraordinário
todos nós podemos fazer algo vai mal
servirá a passar com sacos nos ver e
eficaz ganha novos ajudar só contra uma
fase complicada eu pensar a promover
esta aplicação que eu vou mostrar então
ser um passo para ficar em casa
a irmã já anotada aikau e atropela o
queijo os outros só que com um pouco
movimento
por isso é fácil se foi isso não é meta
o objetivo é ter um ferrari o objetivo
objetivo e tudo que eu faço até lá não é
um objetivo
casar esse flecha o objetivo é todo o
processo até lá não é um objetivo ter um
projeto sonho é tudo que eu faça ter
chegar lá não se eu tiver sol ea pimenta
um dia quando escapava à meta e vou
ficar contente foi a passagem pedir-me
as merdas
eu vou na um sistema eu natal como uma
prenda paulo para 17 fazem parte da
minha vida então tenho nenhuma prática
criminal cattrall mas foi internacional
é claro que éramos dez vezes mais nós
vemos coisas são giras a 1 a 17 a 24 são
todas iguais
na época domingo uma mensagem quando
conduzido pessoal
a mãe até os meus dentes não vou falar
em sexo oral
mas viva o amor é das coisas mais lindas
nós temos e teremos chamar de várias
formas
no cão e os ganhos que mais gosta de mim
quando chegou à casa o goiás recebe um
centro quando eu sou às vezes mãozinha
papel passa muito tempo fora de casa mas
josé não ser um curso estão no olímpico
às vezes chega em casa exausto para casa
deitar me jogar está a olhar pra mim se
amparando boi faz qualquer coisa
esta é a única foto minha e do meu corpo
está na internet
é importante trabalharmos é importante
ficar nos assumir como uma uma profissão
como ser palhaço eu podia ser palhaço
amplia-se política podia ser dos
acusados josé sócrates mas todas estas
profissões que exigem trabalho a sujar
chances e doutor palhaço é só pegar no
nariz para o hospital e fazer as suas
foi isso não é tudo
temos que trabalhar para criar muito
rapidamente um exemplo que eu achei
muito interessante
fizeram um estudo com um jovens
penso que até os 11 anos você ouve não
sabe concretamente 82% pessoas estavam
do méxico comece a talento somente
começou comprimido ou supositório mas
fosse opositor um supositório talento 80
e 82 pessoas queriam que o comprimido
que questionou o cristiano ronaldo é
quem é que trabalho custam de imensa
trabalhar porque costumava como é porque
custava natural e como é comum de voz
estão aqui são condição está muito
trabalho pra trás e os admiro muito este
pessoas que assentam os seus
envolvimento em trabalho muitas vezes
dizemos que falharem mal não só falha
portanto quanto mais melhor
a empresa faliu com disse o morador
naquela manhã quando acordo às vezes
minha mulher maria e uma romaria a
falhar é importante falha cria empresa
faliu o caso envolvendo que romão teve
uma relação foi eu caí tem uma amizade
foi eu vou ver o que correu mal agora
temos sim fazer aí depois de falhar ver
o que é que falhou
nós temos melhor equipa semelhante em
minha opinião só os seus campeões
defende ótimo
é importante haver diferença
o foco é a sua missão como já disse a
missão da nossa instituição e dar um
melhor os mais velhos se você jogar ea
vossa volta tudo que está não foi feito
com mil dez anos foi pessoas mais velhas
e tenho uma mensagem para vocês todos
vocês vão ficar melhores 40 por cento
como retângulo de 40
o automóvel o bicicleta o tratamento e
os outros 20% por outras coisas enquanto
questão sejam feliz de vir tons e
estejam atentos ao próximo e se puderem
façam essa mudança é fácil mudar o mundo
muda em um dos mais baixos - em caso de
vós e vós e vossos pais e da redenção o
melhor de vocês eu não vou passar nita
estou sempre me a mim às vezes é fácil
que o caica condicionado e outras vezes
mas tentaram me fazer força conquistou
trabalhar eu dou o melhor de mim às
vezes tão exausto havia temos tanto
trabalho
vamos trabalhar rast nossa cara parece
quase michael jackson mas damos o nosso
melhor e como é que eu faço eu sou
apaixonada por chocolate quando o
hospital não imagina 24 horas no
hospital de viseu tal médicos surfista 8
com disso azuis atingido meu
imagine toda a gente esclareça
espetacular algumas palavras que eu
queria partilhar convosco pode enfrentar
agora pela tenda se quiserem
viva o pai tem toda a gente todos a seu
favor o racista os topos de propriedade
com ser cultura e gastronomia
extraordinária esteve em cabo verde a
trabalhar no hospital na ilha do sal e
conseguiu um povo tenha kassupá provar a
gastronomia de um povo que o fez um
índice subiam a chupar item sejam
julgados porque ele é importante
partilhar com quem acha pé galinha dos
ovos de ouro e fica com ela ou quem fica
com elas porque ela já imagina meu
partido de sempre - com os meus amigos
as dívidas às finanças as multas a mãe
envolvam se aplica se cuidem se então
acabar o tempo para terminar uma
história pra vocês verem como é super
fácil mudar o mundo a contar quantas
vezes nos dizem
no final da segunda guerra mundial o
jovem de 17 anos estava na camerata
comandará na mão com os colegas e eu
disse que queria mudar o mundo toda a
gente que o socorreram
toda a gente sofreu é toda a gente fez
bonito que é um qualquer jovem porque eu
queria que toda a gente começa a comida
que ela ia cozinhar
imagine um italiano que com esta pasta
comer uma comida chinesa que gostam de
sushi
como era com israel em vez de ficar
triste transformou o mundo de uma vacina
que já não é possível mudar um pouco do
assunto lado só aconteceu na casa de
banho do mundo mas que tem a cabeça na
porta de um raio de vender a coisa
aconteceu entanto lado 10 nunca consegui
um acerto para trás bater em uma coisa o
que era não era um campeão e para
terminar o último conselho consegue nada
podem agora desligar mesmo neste mundo
real
faça o que fizer na vossa vida faça um
cochilo para que quando as pessoas
olharem pra vocês verem sempre melhor
faixa
[Aplausos]